welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of House of
the Dragon episode 7 where Miguel
saposhnik says you thought the battle
Winterfell was hard to see hold my
coffee cup don't worry maybe the hour of
the owl but I got the eyes of one and
neither have been sliced out yet by my
nephew so I'm gonna break down this
episode frame by frame for all the
details you might have missed the
opening credits were updated again this
time showing Lane as dial filling with
blood which is what happens when a
character has died also now we know that
her braid sigil is a rope pattern that
border sarcophagus the fact that this
was her sigil in the last episode's
credits before she even died suggests a
pretty dark view for all of these
characters Fates their fortune and Peril
is all destined set in stone before life
even flows into them a similar Fate has
befall in the dial for sir Harwin strong
once visible to the right of Rainier's
bloodline flowing into hers for their
sons now flooded to mark his death last
episode we open on the funeral of Elena
valarian on driftmark driftmark is the
title of this episode we actually start
with a close-up of rope threaded through
an eyelet Lana's rope will actually
prove critical this episode for it is
her rope that forms the Reigns aemond
grabs to take control of Lena's Dragon
bagar and also take the symbolic Reigns
of power as the battle looms over which
faction of the family will ultimately
Reign the mourners are spread out across
the Rocks including three women whose
faces are shrouded in Black these might
be other mourners like rhaenys who also
has her face stranded like this but
their positioning the fact that there's
three of them there makes me wonder if
they are silent sisters in order of
women from the faith of the seven Who
oversee funeral services their
association with the stranger who
represents death and there being three
of them reminds me of the fates of Greek
mythology who share one eye among the
three of them or even maybe the three
prophetic witches of Macbeth in either
case fitting harbingers for this episode
of Fate doom and one-eyed Vision
vehman's High Valyrian words reference
the Merlin King this is a mythological
figure from whom coralese's Legend has
it he was granted the Driftwood Throne
Otto Hightower has returned reclaiming
handed a king that Lionel strong has
been taken off the board the amend uses
some strong words here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Valyrian speakers all React to what
they meant to saying viserys Rainier and
Damon with his laugh because women is
implying that Elena's daughters are of
trueborn Valyrian blood unlike Vernier
and lenor's Sons it's a charge that
demon irreverently laughs at I don't
think out of disrespect for his late
wife because there was a deleted scene
from last episode that showed that he
loves his family deeply really I think
he's just laughing at the insanity that
someone would use this occasion to make
legitimacy accusations but also yeah
Damon is totally a troll now thanks to
vesi for sponsoring this video House of
the Dragon makes it perfectly clear that
being a Targaryen ain't all it's cracked
up to be yeah there's dragons but
there's also a lot of betrayal and
Intrigue and pretty intense battles and
like gross sex look if it were me and if
I was gonna be sloshing through the
battlefield drench or the blood of my
enemies I'd rather be certain that my
feet stay dry so I would rather be
wearing my besties Bessie is here to
keep you looking good while keeping your
feet dry besties are the perfect
everyday shoe they're sustainably made
knit sneakers that are 100 waterproof
they are made with this diamond text
material that's super easy to clean with
just a rinse of water no I spilled water
all over my pizza my Oinky oinkies are
bone dry like the densy thanks Messi so
if the weather is wet or if it's muddy
besties can help you besties are my
go-to shoes by my door check them out in
the link below for a pair of your own
Bessie shoes laying as sarcophagus gets
dropped into the sea and we follow it to
the depressing bottom where it lands
among a heap of others from house
Valerian making this essentially a mass
grave there really is little dignity
here five dragons appear on driftmark
the highest in the sky is either melees
who is raining this dragon or sea smoke
lane or its Dragon I don't think it's
bagar because there's no holes in the
wings and also later when Eamon sees
vegar that dragon is even larger despite
being above the cloud layer so yeah I
think it's either melees or sea smoke
then directly over the castle it's
caraxis that's Damon's Dragon the golden
one that flies over us is Cyrax it's
Rainier's Dragon the golden one that's
sitting on the cliffs is Sunfire that's
aegon's dragon and then the blue one
sitting above him is dreamfire that's
Helena's Dragon that's a dragon that's
scared amen the last episode The Dragon
whose egg Damon stole in episode 2 and
found back the same Dragon who will
produce the three eggs that Daenerys
Targaryen will receive now after having
her hair down last episode upon the
birth of her son Joffrey raniera's hair
is now back up in a braid matching the
interlocking Circles of the sigil the
Valyrian steel necklace that Damon gave
her her hair was also braided in episode
3 and in episode 4 when she was at that
impressionable age and had some major
hots for her uncle the necklace she now
wears I could be wrong but I think it's
a modified version of that necklace it
uses the Valerian steel rings as a base
changes Out The Chain but has added more
gold around that Central Ruby this is
important because when she walks outside
she starts out of focus but then becomes
clear suddenly and in the reaction shot
that it cuts away too proves that the
point of view of that shot was Damon so
Rainier was walking out into this
cocktail hour presenting herself
directly to Damon but then after some
steak eye from Allison renera turns away
and beelines for her son Jace just like
in last episode when Nera is desperate
to keep her sons in her arms whenever
she senses Allison's presence Chase
wishes they were at harrenhal morning
his true father but when air tells him
to comfort Reyna and Bayla and then she
catches Allison's still stink eye in her
and Emma Darcy does this fantastic
self-conscious adjustment as if she's
worried she might be leaking milk again
bug girl Helena plays with a spider
full of Green dragons
flesh weaving dragons of thread oh bug
girl bug girl sees the future from far
but girl knows just who you are that's a
reference to the Disney show bug juice
they'll get it there will be one viewer
who gets that last week I speculated
that Helena could be a green Seer a work
or a dreamer and this episode confirms
it especially with what happens to
Eamonn he will have a dragon one day
he'll have to close an eye I may have
lost an eye
now Helena is repeating this phrase
about a spool of green and a spool of
black referring to the greens team
Allison and the blacks team renera the
threads referring both to the Wardrobe
they used to define themselves but also
spiders weaving webs the idea of weaving
from a loom these are classic symbols of
fate and destiny Helena smashes the
spider in a seashell as if trying to
stop this faded Dance of the Dragons
here at driftmark but we cut immediately
from this shot of the spider to Laris
strong as he closes his hand around his
firefly-headed Cane now I know it's more
likely that Helena is a Targaryen
dreamer than a westerosi green sear I
get it but I really do think that there
is a connection between Helena's
prophetic bugs and larisa's association
with bugs and Horticulture like Glarus
really could be a wargar green sear
using things like rats to spy on others
around the castle whereas Helena could
be a dreamer and both these people in
Allison's orbits could produce
contrasting Visions as Jace awkwardly
stands behind Bayless she takes his hand
this is the same thing their mother Lena
did to lanor when she was scared at the
turning in episode one this little
moment fortifies these two as protective
siblings Lord Corliss tells Luke that
Ellen Herrick drift mark one day sorry
I don't want it oh like a little Jon
Snow over here I don't want it I never
have amen nearly comes over to comfort
Bayla and Reina but he stops short of
Chase and at the fire and then they all
hear a dragon roar
[Music]
this is of course of agar and in this
episode it is eamonn's call to action
Corliss angrily tells sir Carl to
retrieve Leonor from trying to join his
sister in the sea and this becomes
another point of contention between
Rainier and Allison because every
suggestion that Lenor has Partners
besides raniera is further evidence to
Elephant that raniera is living a lie
meanwhile viserys tells Damon your girls
the very image of their mother
comfort and an anguish as I well
remember yeah telling us that Emma
remains on his mind as we saw when he
kissed her ring last episode in raniera
haunted by looking so much like Emma
Emma so consumes his thoughts that he
takes a big old dump on his current wife
I'm going to bed am I
shall I see after Queen Alice in your
place Jesus Harold you had to rub it in
Damon tells Otto
Village grows it always wants for
another meal yeah pretty sharp dig at
Otto in his sus connection with the
archmaester Melos of Old Town whose
stubborn use of leeches to treat viserys
nearly killed the king especially
noticeable now that mellos is out of the
picture and viserys is shockingly able
to hang in there Otto finds aegon drunk
on the stairs
brother yeah aegon thinks his
grandfather is his younger brother Eamon
just said in about aegon will eventually
see his brother as a far more assertive
taller of these brothers rhaenys tells
Corliss that she thinks the family is
cursed by the gods for their ambition
cordless responds what is this brief
mortal life
if not the pursuit of Legacy yeah it's a
simple hearty Quest that viserys
pondered about to Lord Lionel in episode
5 wondering what songs would be written
about him rhaenys wants driftmark to
pass not to Luke and Chase but to Bela
and Reina since they are of True
valorian Blood but cordless says history
remember blood and remembers names in
history we'll prove him right because of
the Song of Ice and Fire the blood of
House Lannister effectively controls the
Iron Throne despite them doing all that
in the name of house Baratheon the name
history would remember now at this point
the episode you may have noticed the
visuals were a bit hard to make out on
your home TV it's because Miguel spots
next shot the middle part of this
episode using a technique called day for
night where you shoot a nighttime scene
during the daytime and then you
underexpose the shot either in camera or
you darken in post-production and they
do this because shooting at night risks
getting no light whatsoever into the
lens and thus no visual information
recorded but the problem is if this
isn't done without sensitivity to how
the content is going to be exhibited by
the viewer it might result in a lot of
shots just looking too dark and you
can't make out anything you may remember
a lot of viewers had this issue in the
Game of Thrones episode the long night
pictures also shot by swatchnik now some
snobs may say it's on the viewers to
adjust their settings like knowing how
to turn off motion smoothing I agree you
got to turn off motion smoothing but I
don't think it's a fair comparison there
because I am someone who has adjusted my
brightness to 50 and my contrast all the
way up my color temperature to warm my
TV is only like two years old and I
totally turn off all the lights in my
room and watch this at night but the
imagery was still pretty hard to make
out and anytime HBO's massive white
subtitles came on the screen they
Blinded Me and everything else on screen
I mean people Jordan Peele was able to
use day for night shooting for nope and
produced something that looked great
even on home TV so I beg HBO's directors
to over adjust the contrast and the
color temperature and do at least one
test screening on the crappiest potato
TV you can find from the year 2012 just
to ensure it at least looks visible now
in your audience is assuming that most
of them cannot afford oleds now one
counter argument I will entertain is
that maybe they wanted to keep character
motives a mystery by masking them in
darkness like when Rainier asks did you
love her
we were happy enough
well that in itself is a great
achievement yeah notice how the
Moonlight is behind demon here keeping
his face in Shadow when he answers a
question so it's kind of hard to see how
Matt Smith emoted that line but I just
think Matt Smith is a hell of an actor
and it's done a masterful job keeping
his intent ambiguous even in perfect
lighting so can we just trust the actor
to play the ambiguity instead of masking
his performance with bad lighting renera
says should have forbidden so Owen from
returning to the Revenant
Karen's curse is said to be as strong
now as it was after the conquest it's a
ghost story yes he's referencing the
ghost story of hair in the black whose
curse is said to haunt the residents of
Herron Hall since egg on the Conqueror
burned the castle the demon says it's a
ghost story but this whole debate over
whether this ghost story is real it's at
the core thematic debate of much of
George R Martin's text is there real
magic in this world and if so is it even
powerful or is it all really an illusion
exploited by people just trying to mask
or inflate their true power status but
in this middle section I did truly enjoy
eamon's approach to vegar I love the
shots angled downward from vegar down
upon Eamon as if they're from the top of
a tower the seagulls squawking as they
fly off the top of the Dragon
just these little details conveying the
massive scale of the creature yet when
Eamon slightly touches the Reigns vagar
snaps awake it's so scary for something
so large to be so sensitive Amen to
commands
yeah some new Valyrian words there
johiris of course is High Valyrian for
serve but licurious new it means calm
and once he gets the dragon to purr he
now grabs the reins confidently and
climbs and then he commands
it's obviously meaning fly now eamon's
flight on vegar is fascinating to watch
because it's not the joyride that Jon
Snow's first dragonflight was in season
8 of Game of Thrones this by contrast is
a true struggle he gets tossed around
when vegar shakes off the sand and he
nearly falls to his death during that
vertical Ascent the kid has to painfully
heave himself up on the saddle and even
once he gains control he still nearly
dies again when Birds whiz past his head
this is such a realistic depiction of
how hard it would be to fly a dragon
like this only towards the very end of
this flight because Eamon finally gained
confidence and kind of enjoy it and I
love how composer Ramin jawadi brings
back that House Targaryen theme but
makes a sense of electric strings at the
very end of it
[Music]
the Twins and the boys confront Eamonn
at first we sympathize with aemond for
reminding us of Jason Luke totally
pranked him with a pink dread but in the
same line he tells poor Baylor that the
pig would suit her and we lose all
sympathy for him so Jace goes on the
attack but amen notice actually uses the
tips sir Kristen gave his brother aegon
against Chase last episode and uses his
height as an advantage he kicks Chase to
the ground and then Eamonn hurls the
worst insult he won't die screaming at
Flames stretches your father dead
and so this fight ends with the younger
brother Luke grabbing the dagger and
slicing out eamon's eye now in the book
Bayla and Reyna were not present for
this fight it was actually the youngest
brother Joffrey who was age three in the
book's timeline he's the one who
discovers Eamon trying to climb bagar
and he threatens to rat out aemond but
Eamon pushes him into a pile of dragon
poo that is one big pile of [ __ ] and
that leads to the flight and then the
fight goes down after that it seems like
they left out Joffrey obviously to him
being a baby in this Show's timeline but
they included Bayla and Rayna to make
amons taking a vagar more of an insult
Bala and to ultimately draw the twins
closer to Jace into Luke viserys rages
against the kingsguard king's God has
never had to defend princes from princes
that is the balls on Sir Kristen also
I'm pretty sure he's historically wrong
like there was definitely a bloody
succession crisis between Prince maegor
the future of maegor the cruel and his
nephew and his niece prince aegon and
princess Reina when their father King
Amy's the first that was maegor's
half-brother died when that happened
maegor crowned himself on Dragonstone
and essentially forced whatever the
King's Guard was at that point to pick
sides between the right Bel Air and
between him essentially forced in the
situation where they had to defend
princes from princes then as each of the
parents arrived viserys's position in
front of the Driftwood throne even here
he must preside over this dispute as
king though notice behind him Otto lurks
closer and closer to this Throne as if
eager to snatch any power from behind
the king's back Damon meanwhile watches
all this bickering go down casually
leaning on the door hanging back on the
sidelines much like his mummer
equivalent did in episode four now at
first renira says Luke cunningaman was a
regrettable accident desperate to just
move on and move out of this even though
Chase just told her that amid called
them bastards though when Allison pushes
it notice the change veneer takes she
suddenly pipes up and says the fight was
over the bastard accusation my sons are
in line to inherit the Iron Throne Your
Grace this is the highest of treasons
and notice how Rainier's voice drops she
takes a more commanding tone she calls
her father Your Grace she uses the word
treason all to reframe this trial
putting amend and by extension aegon and
Allison all of them on the defensive and
it totally rattles Allison's you tell me
boy
where did you hear this lie the insult
was training yard Blaster a lot of boys
it was nothing
I asked you a question yeah notice the
camera shifts Focus from viserys to
Alison and then back to viserys in a
single shot revealing Allison's panic
but viserys totally ignoring it because
he was there in their training yard
squabbles last episode Allison was not
so Allison tries out a new tactic she
brings a blanor because Annie focus on
lane or she thinks will ship the focus
to his raniera's sin but viserys presses
on and Eamonn says it was it was shorts
oh I see just kidding it was eman's
brother aegon and then aegon instead of
blaming hearing it from his mom or from
Sir Kristen he just lays it all out we
know
father
everyone knows
just look at them yes this line was
directly from George R Martin's text
that's probably why it hit so hard here
but viserys ignores this and demands
they all make peace and he passes
Allison the same exact way that he did
before when he went to bed and called
her Emma but whereas Allison was silent
there now she has to speak up that is
insufficient
there is a debt to be paid
I just love one of her sons eyes in
return Yes Allison evokes the famous
real world Code of Hammurabi and eye for
an eye but also interesting that she
doesn't initially demand Luke's eye in
particular she just says any one of the
son's eyes just a little tell that in
this moment it's not about proper
Justice against Luke in particular it's
about hurting rhaenyra in that side of
the family in any way possible but she
steadies herself and she escalates so
Kristen
bring me the eye of lucerius valerian
stay your hand no you sworn to
me as you're protecting my queen
love the reaction shot sister Harold
Ramon we have to wonder so Harold's
totally gonna have to come to blows
against her Kristen but sir Harold being
there was likely what led sir Kristen to
back down and then the faithful moment
just an incredible 15 seconds that I
love to support her over and over again
notice that when Allison snatches the
dagger that's what knocks over viserys
and Sir Harold immediately has to tend
to the king falling over and that's what
makes him a second behind so as he
rushes across the room to catch up with
her he has to command sir Kristen at
least three times to stay back but sir
Kristen does not and that's what
requires Damon to step in which makes us
a little worried because the last time
Damon and Sir Kristen squared off sir
Kristen won that fight but everything
around these two women freezes as a
dagger Quivers in the foreground as the
fire rages behind now of course the
dagger is the symbol of the Divide these
two women both practically and
symbolically in so many ways it's framed
between them in the poster as vegar's
eye the dragon that now switches sides
in this episode and remember Flames
reveal the secret of aegon Song of Ice
and Fire that is encoded in the Valerian
steel of this blade and remember that is
a secret prophecy that viserys told
renera but not to Allison and it is that
knowledge that sobered Ramirez childish
impulses and makes her feel ultimately
in the right to prevent Allison from
taking her Birthright from her Allison
says Rainier is entitled she has no
honor Ramirez says Allison has been
hiding under a cloak of her own
righteousness and she says but now they
see you
blood has been drawn and Eamon says do
not move me mother it was a fair
Exchange
I may have lost an eye
but I gained a dragon now in the text
amen does not see this right at this
moment it's actually something he says a
lot later when he looks back on this
moment so for this kid to say it right
now so calmly it's truly a threat to
rhaenyra and her whole side of the
family and so the scene ends with the
battle lines drawn one side the blacks
Damon renira her sons and Corliss on the
other side the greens Allison aymond sir
Kristen and Otto later Allison admits
her mistakes to her father pitched in
with her fingers her habit of picking at
her fingernails has returned but notice
as soon as Otto commends her dirty
tactics Allison stops picking at her
fingers and repositions her hands and
Leonor finally shows up I should have
been there
there should be our house words yeah
Ramirez reply really could apply to
lanor missing the birth of Joffrey
renira missing her mother's death to an
Era missing Allison moving in on her dad
really all these two have done is Miss
stuff raniera watches the massive Green
Bay guard depart with aemond on her back
and two other dragons Sunfire with aegon
and dreamfire with Helena leaving the
greens with three dragons the blacks at
this moment have corrects these Cyrax RX
moraxes probably melees and probably see
smoke so things are pretty even Rainier
tells Damon that both of their lovers
were lost to fire fire is a prison
the sea offers an escape and so they
decide to imprison themselves in Fire
and burn together this episode began
with a funeral and it closes with a
wedding between Rainier and Demon not a
ceremony in the faith of the seven but a
secret Valerian wedding a practice until
now left pretty vague in Martin's text
all it really says is that spouses are
bound quote by Blood and fire and can be
officiated by women here it's depicted
by them cutting their palms and their
lips marking each other's heads with
blood sipping a cup and kissing so that
their blood mixes they also wear these
culty traditional Valyrian robes it's
all very mid-summery and unsettling but
it's interesting that they keep a
maester present for this scene to
justify how this marriage would make its
way in history meanwhile they give the
Escape of the sea to lanor which is
interesting because in the text Damon
truly does bribe sir Carl true dual lane
or to death laner's dead body left
bleeding out in spice town but the TV
series twist lenor's fate to allow him
to live with Carl and essos but more
importantly it poses an interesting
question for the fate of sea smoke who
in the text is later claimed by someone
claiming to be leonor's bastard's son
but here as la long as laner remains
alive sea smoke will remain bonded to
him which means that Lenor will live on
as a wild card option for the blacks and
the dance of the dragons to come but for
now as he and Rainier have told each
other the wise sailor flees the storm as
it gathers you can follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow new Rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]